him with reaction he's the host of
unfiltered there's no such thing as a
filtered damn bongino anyway Dan
bongino's with us and the co-host of the
hit show The Five Geraldo Rivera we all
know there's no uh a filter Geraldo as
well Geraldo I'll just throw the
question at you tell me what Joe Biden
and the Democratic Socialist tell them
tell me what they've done what policies
are working for the American people I'd
love to hear it
well first of all I was brought up to
respect my elders and Joe Biden and I
are the same age so I'm very defensive
of him perhaps more so let me let me
step in in your defense here Geraldo
we're friends damn de bongino will back
me up I promise you you are sharp you
are bright you are articulate you are
engaged you are no Joe Biden Dan I'm
sure you agree
yeah no no doubt about it I mean I'll
let Geraldo take it from here but that's
a bit you're not making the point you
think you're making Geraldo but go right
exactly click it anyway
well I I submit Dan that there are times
when you seem Dazed and Confused but you
know don't know man you're you're half
my age
I feel badly for I feel badly for
President Biden it's obvious this is a
staff failure all around I mean someone
should have reminded him wait a minute
this is wrong with me to do this but I'm
going to add one thing I feel bad for
the country I feel bad for the poor the
middle class people on fixed incomes
that are suffering because of his failed
policies I put them above one person
oh sure sure we do Sean but this is a
case where the White House could have
very easily said he misspoke he
apologizes he's called the family and
regret I mean when I write about or talk
about anybody I check on Wikipedia
whether they're alive or dead I mean my
staffers should have done that his
should have done that they should have
be cleared on the on the teleprompter
and so forth judge him by the policy
it's nice that he had this program to
end world hunger that should be what
we're talking about particularly with
this horrible mess in Florida so many
people suffering we need a president who
is compassionate we have a governor down
there who's compassionate and effective
DeSantis so they're doing they they're
working in a bipartisan way I'm not sure
this is the day where we single out a
guy's flub uh you know when it could
have very easily been corrected by a
staffer
again okay number one on the Dazed and
Confused thing my brother you were like
a Studio 54 guy back in the day so I'm
gonna take a hard pass on days then
because you probably peraldo there were
probably Decades of your life you don't
even remember so I'm gonna that's
another story
but we can another time maybe on a radio
show or something but having said that
no you're reading this thing entirely
wrong okay uh respect for your elders
and respect for the power of the office
of the presidency are two different
things I respect my elders I'm not mad
at Joe Biden because he's clearly
suffering some kind of frontal lobe
deficit that a lot of senior Americans
at that age it may be me too at that age
will suffer it's a serious thing you
know I went to graduate school for
neuropsychology I'm very serious about
this stuff it's not it's not a joke it's
not funny having said that the man's the
commander-in-chief are the most powerful
military machine in the history of
planet Earth I mean he could literally
not figuratively annihilate the planet
tomorrow morning
um it's not too much to ask to you know
to have the guy know who's alive and
dead in a room especially when you're a
rather prominent congresswoman who was
involved in an accident just about
everybody involved in politics knows
about here's Point number two that
you're missing too you know I've got a
little bit of experience in this space
the president of the United States every
single footstep he takes is marked out
everything he's going to do is put down
and he's briefed on it you will do this
you will work a rope line right to left
you will exit stage left you will take
six pictures six police Two Fire photos
afterwards everything he does is lying
down how the hell is this guy always
confused about what to do after an event
I'll tell you you don't see this with
any other president not to the degree
with this guy why is it I've done a
hundred of these events if not more
because they brief them on what to do
he's clearly cognitively impaired and he
forgets it's oh World though it's no
more complicated
what about the Emmys what about the
Emmys the Academy Awards a person wins
the statuette then they don't know where
to go they don't know where to go
because it's a it's a new setting a new
kind of physical space
at the Academy Awards Are you seriously
putting these two people on par come on
man this you're not being serious right
now you're telling me like Brad Pitt and
Joe Biden have the same level of
importance Brad Pitt was the was the guy
in uh in that Christian Slater movie who
was Dazed and Confused on the couch
wasn't he it's not the same job man I
mean come on the guy is the
commander-in-chief of the United States
military if you're telling him exit
stage right shake hands with this guy
and leave and he forgets five minutes
later you know or all the one more thing
I don't want to monopolize a segment but
we're not the only ones watching this Xi
Jinping Kim Jong-un and Vladimir Putin
are watching this too they clearly know
the
Vladimir Putin ask Dan my brother asked
Vladimir Putin whether or not Joe Biden
is formidable or senile ask him about
how U.S intelligence
on Putin's invasion of Ukraine and have
backed you let me let me get this back
on track I want to ask a question and
stun the regressions Geraldo yeah do you
believe everybody around Joe Biden sees
what we were talking about do they see
what's happening to this guy yes or no
are they aware of it probably more I
don't know probably way more than
happening to this guy Sean
Geraldo if I saw you on TV no and you
were and this was you on a regular basis
I would fly to where you are I would sit
down with you and I'd say you've had an
incredible 50-year career please please
it's time to retire
but you're not that way 52 and I
appreciate the sentiment I do get a
point because you would be kind to me he
he's the
neglected
kind Dan Sean I gotta get a word in here
I'm sorry could be kind you want kind
get a freaking dog bro this is the
president of the United States you want
a dog to like you know lick your feet my
dog is great she's a submissive she pees
when I come in now she gets so excited I
yeah I don't want the president doing
that too I mean come be kind and in your
point before about Vladimir Putin thinks
Biden's a tough guy he waited for Trump
to leave office before he invaded
Ukraine what are you talking about I
mean I don't even know how that makes
any sense he invaded Ukraine and as a
result Russia is going down the Primrose
path much to the Chagrin of many people
on the right and not after killing uh
Biden did the right thing and he has
done the right thing
all right let's give Dan the last word
tonight we started with you Geraldo okay
yeah I I just don't know what you're
talking about he clearly is not
respected by world leaders when Trump
was in office there was no serious
threat to cross the straight into Taiwan
by China that's happening every day now
the Lord Kim jong-un's threatening his
seventh nuclear test and Vladimir Putin
is annexing portions of Ukraine I have
no idea what you're talking about but
they respect this guy They're laughing
at him I wish they weren't I'm a U.S
citizen I'm proud of my country but
let's not let's not be silly here nobody
respects this guy
Dan good to see you and thank you and by
the way I had one other name Geraldo
Bernie Sanders the sharpest attack he's
older than than Biden true he's not he
doesn't skip a beat this guy uh he's got
three houses where's Jackie or shaking
thin air
kind of embarrassing all right thank you
both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else